ce par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'être octroyé à un pouvoir de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'essaie de trouver des
réponses mais émettra 20 si jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question l'a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio c'est
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
et
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il n'y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique mais c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
de l'année
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 25 janvier paris et
berlin prenne à bras le corps la crise
ukrainienne le président français et le
chancelier allemand ont tenu une
conférence de presse ce soir pour une
réponse commune des discussions dans le
cadre du format normandie c'est ce que
prône ce soir les deux hommes tous deux
appellent à une désescalade détention et
au dialogue avec moscou emmanuel macron
qui prévient que la riposte sera bien là
en cas d'agression le président français
qui a par ailleurs annoncé un échange
téléphonique avec vladimir poutine
vendredi matin notre décryptage avec nos
invités dans quelques instants
des insultes de joe biden en guise de
réponse à une question d'un journaliste
de la chaîne fox news qu'il n'a pas
apprécié une nouvelle gaffe hier soir du
président américain qui pensait son
micro éteint alors faut-il y voir un
signe de nervosité d'un président
confronté à une cote de popularité en
berne l'inflation aux états unis a
atteint un niveau inédit depuis 40 ans
analyse à suivre dans cette émission
depuis houston
la lutte anti qu'ovide en france 9
millions de personnes pourrait perdre
leur pass vaccinale le 15 février faute
de dose de rappel déclaration
aujourd'hui d'olivier verront le
ministre de la santé qui tentent aussi
de rassurer suite à l'apparition du sou
vaillant bea points 2 selon lui pourrait
être plus dangereux contagieux comique
rod mais pas plus dangereux pourtant
pour le président du conseil
scientifique la vague d'hospitalisation
va être très lourdes jusqu'à la mi mars
alors faut-il s'inquiéter qui croire
comment y voir clair on tente en tout
cas de faire en deuxième partie de cette
émission
[Musique]
au sommaire à 21h la campagne
présidentielle avec des candidats
déclarés ou non c'est selon à la
conquête des français aujourd'hui avant
de se rendre à berlin emmanuel macron et
et en haute-vienne pour évoquer les
problématiques de la ruralité est la
candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse était quant à elle à tours pour
parler justice à gauche aussi on
sillonne la france malgré les divisions
et nick shadow a détaillé son projet
pour la présidentielle alors campagne
présidentielle départ imminent on attend
vos réactions télégramme sur le coin
verte et france
la france et l'allemagne veulent donc
remettre l'europe au coeur de la crise
ukrainienne emmanuel macron est en
déplacement à berlin ce soir le
président français et le chancelier
allemand se sont entretenus pour trouver
une réponse commune et mettre fin au
duel maiden poutine on en parle avec
notre reporter guillemin rossi bonsoir
guillemin que faut-il donc retenir de
cette conférence ce soir
yémalé bonsoir stéphanie et bien en fait
il y à un triptyque qui revient souvent
dans la position européenne dans cette
crise russo ukrainienne et que l'on a à
nouveau entendus au cours de cette
conférence de presse ce triptyque c'est
d'abord unités avec l'otan et ses alliés
donc avec l'ukraine et puis fermeté
vis-à-vis de la russie et enfin appel au
dialogue lors d'ailleurs les mots des
deux dirigeants étaient à peu près les
même il n'y avait guère que l'ordre qui
changeait et je vous propose d'écouter
tout d'abord le chancelier olaf scholz
sur ces questions nous avons été clairs
sur le fait que toute agression
militaire menaçant l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine aurait des
conséquences graves et serez payé au
prix fort
nous sommes en contact avec nos alliés
au sein de l'otan et de l'union
européenne
si l'une des conditions
que nous pouvons également lutter
d'autres façons afin
de mener à une désescalade
nous soutenons ardemment un format de
discussions directes entre notamment les
etats-unis et la russie alors emmanuel
macron quant à lui était un peu plus
loquace j'aimerais d'abord vous faire
écouter l'analyse qu'il a de la
situation actuelle mais surtout cet
avertissement lancé directement à la
russie un avertissement lancé regard
face caméra pendant de longues secondes
avec cet affect que l'on connaît si bien
maintenant chez le chef de l'état
français
nous pouvons aujourd'hui que constater
que la russie est en train de devenir
une puissance de déséquilibre dans le
caucase
aux confins de l'europe et dans quelques
autres régions face à cette situation
nous sommes totalement unie groupe et
coordonnée
en tant que pays membre de l'union
européenne en tant qu'allié au sein de
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord la deuxième chose c'est notre
solidarité avec l'ukraine s'il devait y
avoir une agression
la riposte sera là et le coût sera très
élevé
et l'anguille main event macro comme
d'ailleurs le chancelier allemand ont
tout de même lancé un appel au dialogue
un oui tout à fait stéphanie elle il a
même fait avant ce fameux avertissement
lancé à la russie que vous venez
d'entendre d'ailleurs le mot dialogue et
est un de ceux qui est le plus revenus
sous forme d' hannah fort au cours de
cette prise de parole du président de la
république
ne jamais abandonner le dialogue avec la
russie ait un dialogue exigeant la
france a toujours plaidé pour ce
dialogue il ya un dialogue entre les
états unis d'amérique et la russie il y
à un dialogue entre la russie et l'otan
il ya un dialogue dans le cadre de l' os
c'est eux il y a le dialogue dans le
cadre du format normandie et il ya le
dialogue entre l'union européenne et la
russie
chacun de ces canaux doit être doit être
exploité jusqu'au bout alors guy main au
final qu'est ce qu'on peut conclure de
la position franco allemande sur cette
crise
stéphanie en fait on ne sait pas
réellement s'il y a une une position
franco allemande en tout cas on ne sait
pas si france et allemagne pèseront de
la même manière dans cette crise alors
oui les deux pays ont tenté de se
dégager de la posture martiale que ont
adopté les états unis et l'otan et puis
on l'a entendu on a laissé des deux
côtés au moins la même place au dialogue
et à la fermeté d'autre part on a
davantage entendu on a l'impression en
tout cas d'avoir davantage entendu le
président français au cours de cette
conférence de presse alors c'est peut
être un hasard c'est peut-être une
simple différence d'appétence au
discours entre les deux dirigeants ou
alors peut-être que l'allemagne et
n'hésite à trop critique et moscou comme
elle a pu le faire par le passé au cours
notamment des derniers jours ou alors
encore c'est peut-être tout simplement
emmanuel macron qui est peut-être tentés
de jouer un rôle plus important au cours
de cette crise ce qui servirait
évidemment son image de candidat à la
présidentielle merci beaucoup guillemin
rossi pour ce compte rendu sur cette
conférence de presse ce soir à berlin et
mettront qui continuera d'ailleurs ces
échanges diplomatiques le président
français doit s'entretenir vendredi avec
son homologue russe vladimir poutine il
entend lui proposait donc un plan de
désescalade pendant ce temps les états
unis ont choisi eux de montrer leurs
muscles chose que le kremlin n'apprécie
guère on se rend justement moscou pour
retrouver notre correspondante mélissa
d'estrées bonsoir maylis
washington qui annonce donc avoir placé
jusqu'à 8500 militaires en état d'
alerte un prêt à renforcer les troupes
de l'otan et la réaction ne s'est pas
fait attendre côté russe le
kremlin n'a en effet pas tardé à
dénoncer la mise en alerte de ces
milliers de soldats américains pour
moscou il s'agit là d'une nouvelle
exacerbation des tensions par washington
mais la priorité reste la réponse écrite
que la russie attendait américain à ses
exigences pour garantir sa sécurité
l'écouteur
cela n'affecte pas le cours des
négociations les négociations en fait
ont été achevés dans le cadre de leur
phase actuelle et avant qu'il y ait une
compréhension de comment et quand nous
allons les poursuivre il faut obtenir ce
fameux texte
nous espérons que nous l'aurons cette
semaine mais ce qui se passe au niveau
informationnelle et factuel c'est
l'escaladé des tensions entretenues par
les états unis en avons déjà beaucoup
parler lumière et rien n'a changé
nous suivons ses démarches avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude
au lendemain de l'envoi de navires et
d'avions de combat par l'otan en europe
de l'est la russie a de son côté lancé
ce mardi des manoeuvres militaires dans
le sud ouest du pays d'après le
commandement russe ces opérations un pic
plus de 6000 soldats et vise notamment à
coordonner l'action de la marine et de
l'aviation lors de tirs de missiles face
à cette accumulation de forces
militaires près de l'ukraine on est donc
loin de la désescalade à laquelle
appellent pourtant aussi bien de la
russie que l'occident les deux parties
poursuivent malgré tout leurs dialogues
en plus de l'entretien prévu ce vendredi
entre emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine une réunion aura également lieu
demain à paris entre conseiller
diplomatique français allemands russes
et ukrainiens à malice une trisomie
chrétienne qui a fait la une des
quotidiens russes comment les médias
locaux perçoivent ce dossier
effectivement ce qui se passe
actuellement en ukraine fait couler
beaucoup d'encre en russie le quotidien
gouvernemental rossiiskaïa gazeta accuse
par exemple washington d'attiser je cite
l'hystérie anti russe par tous les
canaux possibles regarde
l'objectif des déclarations publiques de
plus en plus nombreuses des responsables
américains officielle sur l'inévitable
attaques des russes et les sanctions
infernale en guise de réponse défi de
contrôler dans les médias sur les
projets du kremlin d'orchestrer un coup
d'état à kiev est unique faire en sorte
que la russie se résigner au fait que
les enfants et les femmes russes dans le
donbass seront tués par les bataillons
des nationalistes ukrainiens avec des
armes américaines mais comme la russie
ne l'acceptera jamais le feu de la
guerre va inévitablement se répandre en
europe
le journal libéral kommersant envisage
lui aussi la possibilité d'un conflit
armé en qualifiant la situation actuelle
de prélude à une guerre le quotidien
économique pointe notamment du doigt le
rôle joué par l'ukraine dans
l'exacerbation des tensions regarde
malgré la perplexité de kiev face au
début de l'évacuation des étrangers du
territoire ukrainien la partie
ukrainienne contribuer elles-mêmes de
manière décisive à l' escalade de la
vague d'informations concernant une
guerre présumés avec la russie en ce qui
concerne les sanctions occidentales qui
pourraient être adoptées à l'encontre de
la russie en cas d'invasion de l'ukraine
on à lisier astier affirme que moscou
ait l'habitude de ce genre de menaces et
préfère se concentrer sur ses
négociations avec washington au sujet
des garanties pour sa sécurité
merci à maylis d'estrées en direct de
moscou rendez vous donc au sommet les
dirigeants allemand et français suivie
d'une rencontre demain sous le format
normandie et enfin un entretien
téléphonique pour clore la semaine
vendredi donc entre manuel mais cros et
vladimir poutine l'europe serait-elle en
train de revenir en force dans cette
crise ukrainienne que retenir de ces
déclarations des deux dirigeants ce soir
tout de suite c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir sur
ce plateau régis le sommier grand
reporter arte france bonsoir régis avec
nous également
xavier moreau directeur de strap paul
bonsoir jean moreau et enfin edouard
husson
historien spécialiste de l'allemagne
merci à vous d'être là également bonsoir
le président français dont quelques
chancelier allemand évoque ce soit je
cite une très grande unité entre la
france et l'allemagne pour appeler à la
désescalade ce sont les mots d' emmanuel
macron on voit clairement une tentative
ce soir en tout cas un souhait très fort
de revenir au centre du jeu dans cette
crise ukrainienne xavier moreau pour
l'europe jusqu'au là un petit peu
délaissé oui enfin il faut faut
relativiser en fait on avait en face de
nous les deux chefs d'état qui
représentait les deux puissances qui aux
accords de minsk dont on a finalement
peu parlé était censé
garantir que kiev exécute les accords de
minsk c'est de ça dont il est question
est d'ailleurs si vous regardez le plan
de désescalade eux de proposer les
nomades des macros c'est l'application
des accords de mines c'est ce qui avait
été décidé au format normandie par les
quatre présidents en décembre 2019 donc
effectivement une fois de plus paris et
berlin se retrouve pour expliquer qu'il
faut faire la paix dans de basses mais
pour l'instant c'est eux qu'ils ne l'ont
pas fait la moscou a fait pression sur
la république de donetsk est lougansk
pour qu'elles cessent leur offensive en
février
2015 donc ce qui a abouti aux accords de
minsk donc moscou a tenu sa parole en
revanche paris et berlin n'ont rien fait
et s'en sont remis à washington et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je sais pas ce
que va dire emmanuel macron ce qu'il va
faire mais pour venir poutine c'est bien
plus confortable de discuter directement
avec joe biden plutôt qu'avec des
capitales paris et berlin qui pour
l'instant n'ont fait juste qu exécuter
ce que ce que voulait washington edouard
husson une grande unité entre
l'allemagne et la france à nous dise ce
soir emmanuel macron enfin en termes
d'influencé justement sur ce dossier
alors qu'il ya eu un dialogue exclusif
on l'a bien compris avec la russie et
les etats unis ils peuvent revenir
vraiment au centre de ce dossier on sait
peine perdue
moi je vais aborder avec ce qui vient
d'être d'être dit il me semble que c'est
même un peu pathétique si vous voulez
parce que ce sont des mots on est quand
même dans une situation qui est
extrêmement grave puisqu'il y à des
tensions sans précédent dans l'histoire
de l'europe depuis plusieurs décennies
on est revenu à un niveau de tension qui
rappelle les pires heures de la guerre
froide par exemple quand des unités
blindées se sont fait face des deux
côtés du mur de berlin où des chefs des
choses comme ça et est donc on a
effectivement comme
le disait monsieur moreau on a quelque
chose d'évident c'est que depuis 2014 la
france et l'allemagne avaient tout pour
jouer une carte cette carte c'était
celle effectivement du respect d'accords
km qui avait été signé c'était tout à
fait possible parce que le le
gouvernement ukrainien et est
relativement faible et divisée et son
intérêt ça serait plutôt d'être d'être
soutenu efficacement de l'extérieur et
la france et l'allemagne ne joue pas le
rôle est régulièrement viennent se
plaindre de ce que les états unis leur
vole la vedette mais à force de ne rien
faire c'est normal la nature a horreur
du vide et les états unis donnent le la
selon leur intérêt à eux qui ne sont pas
les intérêts européens alors interpellé
en tout cas par les journalistes sur
place sur cette mise à l'écart de
l'europe dans ce dossier emmanuel macron
admis l'impuissance de ce format
normandie tout de même côté
vous avez raison de dire que les
résultats du format normandie ne sont
pas à la hauteur des attentes et de
l'engagement que l'allemagne et la
france ont pu y placer
néanmoins abandonné renoncer c'est acté
que la solution politique n'est plus sur
la table donc je pense qu'il est
important nous de rester engagées sans
relâche la dernière réunion qui s'est
tenue en décembre 2019 au niveau des
chefs d'état de gouvernement avaient
permis des avancées robuste je pense que
la perspective d'une réunion futur la
réunion de nos conseillers diplomatiques
demain et la perspective d'une réunion
futur qui sera organisée
cette fois ci a organisé en allemagne
je pense créer des attentes positives et
permet de réengager les choses emmanuel
macron reste optimiste 1 il dit voilà le
format normandie l'année
annie quelques échecs donc pourquoi ça
marche aurait maintenant alors que ça
n'a pas marché ces dernières années
régis le sommier alors on peut se poser
la question et c'est en effet ça vient
un peu tard on sent bien moi je souscris
à ce qui a été dit avant sur le fait que
la france est mal et l'allemagne qui
étaient les gars ont justement de ces
accords n'ont pas fait leur le job pour
ce qu'ils soient pour des financiers
demandés déverrouiller une situation qui
aurait pu être à arriver à une sorte de
paix il tirait un peu militarisé mais
quand même une paix alors que dans l'est
de l'ukraine avait quand même une
situation vous avez encore des tranchées
vous avez des échanges de feu et est
donc qu'on est dans dans depuis 2014
dans une situation de guerre larvée donc
là la france et l'allemagne arrivent
tard mais il ya quand même une chose qui
est significatif c'est à dire qu'on a
remarqué quand même de la part de
l'allemagne en particulier et de la part
aussi de la france mais pour des raisons
différentes c'est que il y avait quand
même une sorte de de prudence allemande
par rapport à la surenchère qui a été
manifestée par l'otan et par les états
unis et l'angleterre évidemment
l'angleterre
jouant on le voit à nouveau pleinement
son rôle de d'allier fidèles et de
toutous des états unis puisque
l'angleterre libéré de toute contrainte
avec le bras exit est aujourd'hui boris
johnson encore une fois est empêtré dans
des affaires intérieures aussi et avec
des problèmes de cote de popularité se
pressent justement d'empoigné cette
crise ukrainienne et d'agiter le chiffon
c'est aussi ce qu'a fait joe biden alors
peut-être qu'il y a dans le choix
justement de ce dialogue franco-allemand
et dans ses prises en compte par les
français les allemands qui peuvent peser
sur la crise je pense que c'est plutôt
les allemands qui peuvent peser sur la
crise et on sait qu'il ya sept cet
accord gazier avec la russie c'est que
les allemands n'ont toujours pas livré
d'ailleurs leurs armes aux ukrainiens
contrairement aux anglais et
contrairement aux américains donc voilà
il ya une position de prudence avec
peut-être une manière aussi de
ressusciter ce fameux couple
franco-allemand dont on parle
régulièrement dix ans qu'il est au point
mort olaf scholz emmanuel macron sont
deux hommes qui se connaissent très bien
qu'ils ont déjà eu beaucoup de points
communs enfin en tout cas de manière
d'échanger maintenant olaf scholz et
chancelier emmanuel macron et le
président de l'union européenne en fait
le président en dirigeant le dirigeant
de l'union européenne d'ailleurs à ce
titre il se murmure à au quai d'orsay
qui emmanuel macron pourrait en tant que
leader de 2 comme le lieu se rendre à
moscou c'est un projet qui serait à
l'étude évidemment il ya des conditions
qui sont pas réunies la mais pour
rencontrer peut-être directement
vladimir poutine et dans ce cas-là
tenter justement de désamorcer la crise
vous faisiez allusion à cette
problématique du gaz
effectivement gros sujets pour
l'allemagne d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
premier ministre polonais a durement
critiqué l'attitude injustement de
berlin évoquant son inquiétude sa grande
déception scénario noir reprochant
implicitement l'allemagne de penser
d'abord à ses intérêts économiques olaf
scholz lui appelle à ne pas politiser la
sphère du gaz on le comprend un petit
peu quand on va voir la part
d'exportation du gaz russe aux pays
européens regardent et
40% donc de de gaz exporté en dans les
pays européens et russes 18% norvégien
11% algérien edouard husson ça explique
évidemment beaucoup de choses dans
l'attitude allemande parce qu'on sait
qu'au sens d'ailleurs même de la
coalition tout le monde n'est pas
vraiment d'accord pour être ouvert au
dialogue avec la russie mais est ce
qu'on a le choix vraiment du côté de
berlin
alors il ya il ya deux choses la
première vous avez tout à fait raison la
dépendance au gaz russe
de la part de l'allemagne étant donné
que l'allemagne a fait le choix
d'abandonner l'énergie nucléaire et que
les énergies renouvelables ne produisent
pas de l'électricité suffisamment pour
pour l'industrie pour l'industrie
allemande donc ça effectivement c'est
une grosse tension c'est une grosse
pression pardon qui baise qui pèse sur
le l'allemagne je me permets d'attirer
parce que bien sûr il ya toujours des
facteurs matériels qui détermine les
attitudes diplomatique et il faut pas la
nier
l'occurrence mais je me permets quand
même d'attirer l'attention sur le fait
que olaf scholz de tempérament et plus
équilibrée que quand quelqu'un merkel
angela merkel avait une avait introduit
dans la politique étrangère allemande
une hydre russophobie qui est qui était
qui était nouvelle qui ne correspondait
pas à ce qu'avaient fait les chanceliers
ses prédécesseurs et dans ce cadre-là
olaf scholz vraisemblablement va être
plus proche la position d'un helmut kohl
ou d'un gerhard schröder et de ce point
de vue là ça sera plus d'ailleurs parce
que le problème qu'on avait sous la
chancellerie doit pendant la
chancellerie d'angela merkel s'étant
gala merkel avait une diplomatie très
russophobe et gerhard schröder qui comme
vous le savez un siège aux
administrations de de gazprom
rétablissait l'équilibré s'était pas
c'était pas ça du tout ce n'est pas une
bonne chose et là on aura un chancelier
beaucoup plus prudent et
sociaux de garder l'équilibré
traditionnel de la politique allemande
qui est souvent critique vis-à-vis de la
russie mais essaye de ne ne pas aller
trop loin c'était l'attitude de tous les
prédécesseurs de denguele américains le
gaz est sur la liste des sanctions
envisagées par les américains regardent
et un possibles sanctions américaines
sur la russie réduction des achats de
gaz et de pétrole interdiction du dollar
aux banques russes interdiction
d'importer de la technologie et à
l'instant au bénin joe biden un quine
qui décidément ne laisse pas l'europe
trop briller dans ce dossier est en
train de manifestement s'exprimer on a
les urgents de la schl agence france
presse qui tombe à l'instant robin dunne
qui se dit prêt à prendre des sanctions
visant personnellement poutine xavier
moreau est ce que c'est une étape de
plus je vois sourire oui non mais c'est
pas très sérieux les pays ne sanctionne
pas les présidents ça ça ne se fait pas
je pense surtout que joe budden essaie
de se rattraper parce qu'on en a pas
parlé en france mais il a commis une
gaffe il ya quelques jours en parlant
d'incursions mineurs de la russie en
ukraine donc ça a provoqué un élevé de
et une levée de drapeau bien sûr en
ukraine mais également aux états unis
non seulement chez les républicains mais
chez les démocrates donc en fait pour
attraper cette bévue baden en fait des
tonnes depuis trois-quatre jours mais ça
montre au contraire que les états unis
sont limitées dans les sanctions qu'ils
peuvent appliquer à la russie et c'est
déjà un constat qui avait été fait en
2018 à l'époque de donald trump mais
c'est également un constat qui a été
fait qui a été fait par dont récemment
au sein du ministère affaires étrangères
américain d'ailleurs il ya eu la
publication de flou règne à faire ce don
qui est le journal du des affaires
étrangères américaine est une un article
très intéressant qui a été publiée dans
lequel il était souligné que finalement
la russie n'avait pas fait les erreurs
de l'union soviétique que donc son
économie était capable de s'adapter de
protée et de profit les sanctions et
c'est un discours qu'on retrouve de plus
en plus dans la dans la presse
américaine et de toute manière il n'y a
pas d'alternative au gaz russe c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est le premier ministe
norvégien qu'il a dit à 3 jours toutes
les producteurs alternatifs de gaz pour
l'europe sont ont tous atteint leur pic
gazier que ce soit l'algérie que ce soit
là la norvège l'angleterre n'a quasiment
plus je crois et le danemark devrait
totalement cessé sa production cette
année donc le seul endroit où il reste
encore du gaz c'est en russie et c'est
pas le gaz de schiste américain c'est
pas le cas gasquet tahri qui va
compenser les énormes volumes à mon avis
c'est plus que 40% mois d'après mes
calculs on est au dessus de 50 pour cent
donc donc de toute manière même si
jamais il y a des des des sanctions et
bien l'allemagne et la france iront
acheter leur gaz en euros ou en roubles
ou et pas avec des valises de dollars à
la frontière russe donc ce sont des
menaces qui ne mènent à rien le chef de
la banque centrale qui pourtant a plutôt
un libéral non guerman gref de la banque
de la sberbank qui la plus grosse banque
russe a déclaré que de toute manière ça
ne changerait rien la fin du swift ou le
maintien du suisse ne s'en ne changea
rien que la russie était prête donc en
fait washington a très peu de moyens de
faire pression sur la russie en tout cas
washington qui continue à s'exprimer par
la voix manifestement de joe biden qui
accompagnait des journalistes lors d'une
visite d'un petit commerce à washington
nous n'avons pas l'intention de déployer
des forces américaines ou de l'otan en
ukraine voici ce qu'aurait déclaré donc
le président américain
ce soir dans le même temps on entend
emmanuel macron et audacieux nous dire
la riposte sera là si la russie
agressent régis le sommier comment ça
évolue à l'as à la lumière de ces
dernières déclarations selon vous on
trouve le vieux mantra de chez joe biden
de ce qu'on appelle nos bouts de 5,2 g
menace que ce que barack obama avait eu
avait justement compris en n'intervenant
pas en syrie ce que donald trump après
avoir compris qu'ils avaient entre les
mains un juge ou incroyables qui était
le pentagone et avoir fait des frappes
en syrie mais n'a pas ils n'ont pas
déclenché de guerre donc il ya toujours
cette
cette espèce de traumatismes liées à
l'afghanistan et à et à l'irak de ne pas
envoyer des troupes sur sur place donc
là je pense qu'il ya une manière d'une
manière d'essayer de rassurer l'opinion
publique américaine sur le fait que
cette escalade cette guerre si elle a
lieu elle se fera par d'autres moyens
elle se fera par une guerre cyber elle
se fera par des frappes aériennes
fatouma et voilà mais qu'il n'y aura pas
de soldats américains sur place le c'est
important je pense on remarque quand
même un état de de fébrilité chez joe
biden ces derniers ces derniers jours
ces dernières semaines on l'a vu perdre
ses nerfs contre un journaliste de fox
news a utilisé un langage d'ailleurs
très proche du langage de donald trump
quai à l'époque qu'on disait donnant un
peu oui ça peut se permettre d'insulter
et journaliste là ça fait moins
visiblement de de remous mais en tout
cas voilà tout à l'heure non mais c'est
vrai quoi parce que à chaque fois c'est
toujours trop mais c'est toujours le
voilà le lourd aussi etc puis là on
attend audio ben laden qui étaient
censés êtres civilisés qui utilisent le
même langage donc là ça montre une
certaine fébrilité et puis et surtout le
problème qu'a joe biden de des résultats
il n'a pas réussi à passer ces mesures
au niveau interne son propre son plan de
relance pour l'économie
également arrivent les mythes heures
mais on a déjà vu des candidats
démocrates battus dans des fiefs dans ou
très proches d'être battus dans le
new-jersey en virginie est autres qui
était leur fief qui sont des fiefs
historiques démocrate donc c'est très
inquiétant c'est des signes très
inquiétants pour les midterm et joe
biden a une image dégradée je le répète
mais c'est important de le préciser
depuis le retrait américain
d'afghanistan
il ya une voie là les américains ont
bâclé ce retrait au niveau il a besoin
de montrer qu'il est capable de qu'il
est toujours il tient le leadership est
ce qu on en est sûr voilà on en est on
n'en est pas sûr et quant à boris
johnson qui lui même comment on fait
aussi quand vous écoutez maurizio sein
de décrypter les anglais c'est on est
quasiment dans un état de deux guerres
le trafic aérien entre l'angleterre et
l'ukraine a été multiplié par dix dans
les derniers jours et du livraison du
matériel et évidemment ils le disent ils
par le même eu par exemple ont évoqué la
possibilité d'envoyer des troupes donc
voilà il ya deux leaders qui ont des
problèmes énormes à domicile jeudi boris
johnson sur ces petites fêtes au 10
downing street qui commence à attirer
l'oeil de scotland yard dès ce soir il
ya une enquête qui vient d'être ouvert
donc voilà on est avec deux leaders qui
sont critiqués
la question aussi c'est le format du
dialogue moi je pense que le dialogue
direct avec la russie est très le ce que
c'est on dit poutine est très a toujours
des coups d'avancé etc mais là il a
réussi a redit à launay directement avec
les etats-unis en se passant des
européens qu'il a qualifiée de trop
dépendants et donc là ça va être quand
même intéressant de voir comment
emmanuel macron et olaf scholz comment
négocié ou avances non sur cette crise
parce que s'il arrive à déboucher dit
quelque chose s'ils arrivent à faire
bouger les choses eh bien ça montrera
que l'europe n'est pas si impuissante
que ça et que vladimir poutine qui l'a
dit dépendante des états unis verra
peut-être un allié ce qui serait
souhaitable justement et magna
maintenant un peu ironisé quand on lui a
demandé
ce qu'il en pensait de ce dialogue
américano russes et la mise à l'écart de
l'europe il en substance dit ben
regarder le résultat pour l'instant il
n'ya rien mais il faut dire que c'est
compliqué de dialoguer avec la russie le
mot de la fin pour vous edouard husson
si c'est si compliqué de dialoguer avec
la russie quelle peut être la teneur des
échanges vendredi entre emmanuel macron
et vladimir poutine
écoutez moi je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit aussi compliqué de dialoguer avec
la russie quand on est européen
l'intérêt de l'europe c'est une
désescalade nous n'avons pas nous
n'avons pas intérêt à avoir par exemple
des crises de réfugiés qui seront cette
fois ci des réfugiés européen s'il y
avait une guerre on a bien vu récemment
des tensions en biélorussie
ali à des migrants la venue d'ailleurs
qui étaient exploitables par la russie
notre intérêt c'est plutôt la
désescalade et puis c'est aussi à la
prise en compte
du point de vue russe d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron l'avait dit un moment et
puis finalement il a il a abandonné
comme comme à peu près tout ce qu'il
fait série patron est un homme
intelligent qui a quatre bonnes idées et
puis et puis sam il en fait trop en
paroles et pas assez en action ça
s'enlise mais il avait bien dit à un
moment il fallait essayer de comprendre
le point de vue russe c'est si vous
voulez le il ya une et une carte
humoristique qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux qui montre les bases américaines
allaient base de l'otan à proximité des
frontières russes et qu'ils disent et
qui dit quand même regarder les la
russie a mis ses
frontières juste devant nos bases et
effectivement c'est une façon ironique
de souligner que la russie se sont
encerclés et que ça peut se comprendre
je veux dire regarde regardez la carte
des bases russes donc donc il ya je
crois une position de médiation qui
pourrait être celle de l'europe de
l'union européenne au vrai sens du terme
et c'est vrai que si on se rappelle le
la convergence de jacques chirac garde
fraudeurs et vladimir poutine au moment
de la de la première guerre d'irak
pardon de la deuxième guerre d'irak de
stèles de 2003 et bien on peut on peut
se dire qu'il ya du potentiel et encore
une fois je miserais beaucoup sur la
solde qui est un homme plus modéré que
qu'angela merkel et surtout avec une
vision plus réaliste de ce que devrait
être la politique étrangère allemande et
la politique vis-à-vis de la russie
merci en tout cas tous les trois edouard
husson résiste au sommet sur ce plateau
et xavier moreau merci pour ce
décryptage ce soit
et on en parlait justement joe biden
aurait-il perdu ses nerfs hier soir
interrogé sur la montée de l'inflation
par un journaliste de la chaîne
conservatrice fox news le président
américain a botté en touche il a même
traité son interlocuteur de tous les
noms d'oiseaux pensons son micro et un
insigne peut-être d'une certaine
fébrilité à la maison blanche à
lapproche les élections de mi-mandat
médiers ski fis on connaissait les
petites phrases de donald trump il y
aura désormais les insultes de joe biden
interrogé par un journaliste de fox news
ce lundi sur l'inflation le président
américain a répondu dans un langage peu
approprié pensant peut-être que son
micro était éteint
c'est un grand atout plus d'inflation
espèce de file de
une nervosité chez le président
démocrate qui s'explique peut être par
le caractère sensible du dossier évoqué
par le journaliste l'inflation atteint
en effet des niveaux records depuis 40
ans et affecte le pouvoir d'achat de
nombreux américains autre signe
d'inquiétude
la cote de popularité du locataire de la
maison blanche un récent sondage de
l'institut gallup indique notamment que
celle ci accuse une forte chute auprès
de la population suite à cette sortie
verbal musclé le camp républicain n'a
pas tardé à réagir
tellement présidentielle
deux poids deux mesures
les règles ne s'appliquent pas aux m ois
fox
comment joe biden at il osé attaquer le
premier amendement comme ça une telle
menace pour notre démocratie
ce sont les règles non le 46e président
des états unis il n'en est pas à son
coup d'essai la semaine dernière il
s'était agacé en qualifiant d' idiote la
question posée par une autre journaliste
de fox news un an seulement après sa
prise de fonction le président de 79 ans
enchaîne les faux pas en public
notamment en présence de la presse une
situation qui pourrait bien pénalisé le
camp démocrate
à dix mois des élections de mi mandat et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston aux états unis avec dave
perkins soutien de donald trump analyse
politique animateur radio c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir et perkins merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous alors à ceux-là polimique de
trop pour joe biden on le sait quand
même faut que ce musée est ouvertement
pro trump et attaquent frontalement joe
biden comment les les américains
réagissaient ce qui lui pardonne
finalement ses agacements et le trouve
légitime où est-ce qu'ils sont choqués
aujourd'hui
pour
les sites amis fans et les médias se
fait mais de la façon dont donald train
de parler de cette façon d'une façon
trop et grossière bouche d'or mais rien
sur donald trump n'a jamais utilisé
cette insulte que joe biden l'a utilisé
aujourd'hui dans les plinthes nouveau
trio n'a
jamais insulté m 2 par sant brieg fourni
adjugé apporté deux microphones ensuite
à les interactions alors qu'il ya
beaucoup de pression et d'enjeu bas sur
la table
des causes qu'ils veulent
indulgents envers joe biden car on se
rend compte qu'il est âgé et qu'il n'est
plus aussi alerte qui mettait ya
longtemps
et cela fait 40 ans qu'il est dans la
vie publique et il a toujours montré du
mépris envers les journalistes qui lui
posaient des questions compliquées et il
n'a jamais hésité à le montrer du jeu
baydan considère la personne la plus
intelligente il dans la pièce et
lorsqu'on lui pose des questions
compliquées
il
considère que c'est un esprit inférieur
qui remette en question sa supériorité
intellectuelle et aujourd'hui c'était
encore le cas et cela pourrait arriver
il fait cela depuis les années 1970
il ne filtre pas ces propos et où là une
idée à très haute de lui-même alors ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il ya une
petite anicroche avec des journalistes à
la semaine dernière après une longue
conférence de presse lors de laquelle il
avait promis d'aller davantage au
contact des américains il avait déjà
fait part de son agacement murmurant
quelles questions idiotes est-ce qu'il
ya là une rupture quand même avec les
journalistes aujourd'hui aux états unis
entre les présidents et une partie en
tout cas des médias
tout à fait je vais expliquer cette
aventure
le problème c'est que les électeurs se
détournent de turbin tonnes chaque fois
qu'un sondage publié le taux de
popularité régional gones après c'est le
jaune reste commencent à se rendre
compte que je balden non par coop l'ère
du tout et qu'il quittera au parti
démocrate au loin à l'autre suivant ou
lors des deux prochaines élections est
la victoire il s'essaye de rendre le web
louis devient candidat trop grâce à vos
prières pour que le parti démocrate se
débarrasse de lits jeu madden représente
un handicap rodolphe
wassila progrès pour l'ouverture il est
susceptible de dire n'importe quoi à
n'importe quel moment comme hors de
cette presse conférence de presse parce
qu'il a dit quelque chose qui aurait pu
être considéré comme un revers pour
vladimir poutine
enfin le creps aux états unis s y
opposent il représente l'avion un
problème pour le parti démocrate et elle
est journaliste l'attak afin que le
parti démocrate puisse facilement s'en
débarrasser alors c'est ce qui se cache
derrière en tout cas on voit que la cote
de popularité est en chute libre évalué
à 39% c ces derniers jours à dix mois
des élections de mi-mandat on avait
promis aux états unis davantage de calme
en tout cas les démocrates le prométhée
moins de fracture au sein des 50 états
est ce que finalement c'est aujourd'hui
le cas ce qu'on a à faire à une amérique
au moins plus apaisé dans son climat où
les choses se sont peut-être empirer
dans les mois de juin la situation s'est
aggravée et je vous en donnerai dans la
meilleure mesure en matière de rallye
même trop bien simplement les bras du
parti démocrate à la chambre des
représentants ont déjà démissionné et ne
se représenterait pas lors des versions
le produit quasiment caractères du parti
démocrate ont démissionné et ne se
représenterait pas lors des prochaines
élections je pense que c'est la première
fois que cela arrive en tout cas au
cours de ma vie
cela démontre bien l la popularité est
elle le place des problématiques de joe
biden merci beaucoup dave perkins un
rappel vous êtes soutien de donald trump
et analyses politiques animateur de
radio merci de nous avoir apporté en
tout cas votre point de vue ce soir
et en amérique du sud crise politique au
honduras le pays se retrouve avec deux
présidents du parlement une situation
inédite lors de l'élection une partie de
la majorité s'est retournée à la
surprise générale contre le candidat
pressenti plongeant les en sûrs à 100
l'incapacité d'exercer le pouvoir
législatif à seulement deux jours de
l'investiture de la nouvelle présidente
kio mara castro les détails avec antoine
ogier une élection au congrès national
qui a failli se transformer en bagarre
générale
alors que tout laissait penser que luis
redondo serait élu à la tête du
parlement du honduras au dernier moment
18 députés de la majorité se sont alliés
à la surprise générale un des partis de
droite pour désigner un autre candidat
georges calix élus à 83 voix sur 128
selon le ministère de l'intérieur les
députés restés fidèles à la présidente
élue guyomar à castro crient au coup
d'état institutionnel alors qu'ils ont
fait c'est présenté une motion ils ont
pris le document et sont allés prêter
serment mais personne n'a voté ici cela
signifie qu'il n'avait pas les votes
cela signifie qu'ils ont réalisé qu'ils
allaient perdre et ils ont pris d'assaut
le congrès national dès le lendemain la
nouvelle présidente du honduras et ses
partisans se sont mobilisés devant le
congrès pour empêcher que georges calix
ne puisse prêter serment permettant
ainsi à luis redondo de se prêter à
l'exercice
les députés du congrès national ont agi
opportunément dans le but de réaliser
une action qui devait être exécuté ce
jour en vue de prendre le contrôle par
les structures criminelles qui ont
gouverné ce pays ils avaient l'intention
de prendre le contrôle de ce pouvoir
législatif
présente devant le congrès pour
féliciter le nouveau président du
parlement jomar à castro a profité du
bain de foule pour justifier son action
[Musique]
le peuple s'est prononcé et nous devons
le respecter si nous en tant que peuple
hondurien continuons à accepter ces
pratiques alors ce qui va se passer dans
les faits c'est que le parlement
redonnera le contrôle de son pouvoir
d'état le pouvoir législatif à la
dictature
problème à quelques kilomètres de là
georges calix a également prêté serment
et s'il a tenu à affirmer que sa
présidence travaillerait étroitement
avec zoumara castro il n'empêche que le
honduras a désormais de pouvoirs
législatifs en concurrence
je demande aux honduriens d'être
vigilants et de veiller à ce que la
présidence du pouvoir législatif
travaillent main dans la main avec la
présidente du homard à castro dans
l'intérêt de tous les honduriens
le groupe de puebla qui regroupe des
dirigeants progressistes d'amérique
latine et l'armée honduriennes ont
apporté leur soutient la présidente
qualifiant le retournement de veste
georges calix et de 18 monde de la
majorité de trahison impardonnable dans
l'attenté d'un dénouement le honduras se
retrouve donc dans l'impasse politique à
quelques jours seulement de
l'investiture de guyomard à castro
au royaume uni le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson est désormais
au coeur d'une enquête de scotland yard
la police saisit de la sphère des fêtes
organisées dans sa résidence pendant les
confinements dernières révélations date
le 19 juin 2020 au moment où les
britanniques étaient soumis et des
restrictions
sébastien à bas
la fête pourrait être bientôt fini pour
boris johnson la metropolitan police la
police britannique a ouvert une enquête
sur les festivités du his darling street
un parti gates qui a ulcéré les
britanniques
je peux confirmer que la police
métropolitaine est désormais en train
d'enquêter sur un certain nombre
d'événements qui ont eu lieu au 10
downing street au ces deux dernières
années en relation avec de potentiels
violation des restrictions psycho vie de
10,9 je dois souligner que le fait que
nous enquêtions ne signifie pas que des
amendes seront nécessairement prononcé
dans chaque instance et pour chaque
personne impliquée
une annonce attendue par l'opposition et
la population qui critiquaient le
silence de scotland yard sur ces
révélations pour rappel ces
rassemblements avaient lieu alors que
les britanniques étaient contraints par
la loi à restreindre leurs contacts le
locataire du 10 downing street interrogé
au parlement a réagi à l'ouverture de
l'enquète
je salue donc la décision du maire de
mener sa propre enquête car je pense que
cela contribuera à apporter au public la
clarté dont il a besoin les à mettre un
terme à cette affaire mais je tiens à
rassurer la chambre monsieur le
président et le pays que moi même et
l'ensemble du gouvernement nous
concentrons à 100% sur les priorités des
citoyens y compris le rôle de premier
plan du royaume uni dans la protection
de la liberté dans le monde
mais le chef du gouvernement comme s'il
était coincé dans une boucle sans fin
doit à présent faire face à un nouveau
scandale dévoilé ce lundi soir par la
presse britannique le 19 juin 2020 une
fête aurait été organisée pour
l'anniversaire du leader du parti
conservateur jusqu à 30 personnes y
auraient participé dont l'architecte
d'intérieur chargé de rénover
l'appartement du premier ministre et
dont le financement est controversée
dans la sphère politique les soutiens de
boris johnson se démène pour sauver leur
chef de file alors que ses opposants
font tout pour l'amener à la démission
le premier ministre qui vous le savez
était à l'article de la mort quelques
mois plus tôt à cause du coc vie 19
travaillé incroyablement dur s'était
absenté s'était vu offrir un gâteau un
peu plus tôt dans la journée avant de
revenir à son bureau où il travaille
avec les mêmes personnes avec qui il
collabore au quotidien et qui avait
décidé de lui offrir un gâteau pour son
anniversaire claires les règles sont
claires vous ne pouvez pas participer à
une fête avec plus de deux personnes en
intérieur
ce que l'on sait c'est que 30 personnes
étaient rassemblées que sa femme était
présente et que l'architecte d'intérieur
était là aussi s'il s'agissait de mon
anniversaire et que ma femme est une
architecte d'intérieur vous les relâcher
la pression au travail avec un gâteau
d'anniversaire et une fête se serait
brisé les règles il n'est pas question
d'avoir dans notre pays la moindre
personne moi y compris qu'ils
s'imaginent au dessus des lois dans ces
circonstances le premier ministre
devrait simplement démissionner laisser
la place et participe en choeur les
conclusions de l'enquêté sont
particulièrement attendus par
l'opposition il faut 54 députés
conservateurs pour déclencher un vote de
défiance qui pourrait amener le chef de
l'état à démissionner
on en vient à la situation sanitaire en
france qui continue d'inquiéter pays
d'europe le plus touché avec 500
nouvelles contaminations enregistrés ces
dernières 24 heures du jamais vu olivier
veyrat indiqué que le pil devrait être
bientôt atteint le ministre de la santé
qui est revenu sur l'apparition vue sous
variés ambea points 2 ils pourraient
circuler plus largement mais serait
moins dangereux comique rhône le
président du conseil scientifique qui
guide le gouvernement estime lui que la
vague d'hospitalisation va être très
lourdes jusqu'à la mi mars
on pourrait se recontrent mines et
potentiellement au ba2 même lorsque nous
aurions été contaminées en variant
omicron ce qui pourrait conférer un
avantage concurrentiel aux ba2 qui
pourrait du coup circuler un peu plus
largement
la vague sur l'hospitalisation elle va
être très lourdes sur la france jusqu'à
à peu près la mi mars moi je vois tes
airs les choses plutôt vers la mi mars
avec une baisse progressive très lente
en termes d'hospitalisation et un nombre
de contaminations qui va doucement finir
par baisser alors depuis le la crise
sanitaire les variantes du coït ce
succès delta omicron est donc maintenant
bea pointe de que sait-on aujourd'hui de
se souvenir y ont fait le point avec
estelle fages
on connaissait les variants voici venu
le temps des sous variant après delta le
nouveau variant du coc vite 19 a été
nommé omicron mais comme l'expliquent l'
oms omicron est en réalité un terme
générique qui désigne plusieurs lignage
de virus similaires ainsi chez le terme
omicron englobe donc plusieurs sous
variant l'organisation mondiale de la
santé on a identifié trois qu'elle
considère comme préoccupants ba1 ba2 et
ba3 ces dernières semaines le omicron
dont le monde entier parlait était en
réalité le béa 1 mais c'est désormais le
béa 2 qui attire l'attention en devenant
notamment le sou vaillant majoritaire en
inde et au danemark en france où il a
été détecté les scientifiques cherchent
à connaître précisément ses
caractéristiques
ce qui nous intéresse c'est si ce sous
variant possède des caractéristiques
différentes en termes de contagiosité
d'échappement immunitaire ou de sévérité
les experts regarde oncle ba2 avec
beaucoup d'attention interrogé sur le
sujet le président du conseil
scientifique estime que la grande
interrogation réside dans le niveau de
dangerosité de ce sous variant il a
l'air de prendre le pouvoir s'il prend
le pouvoir au danemark et qu'ils
expliquent la situation au danemark cela
veut dire qu'il est plus transmissible
encore la question posée de savoir
quelle va être sa gravité donc on le
regarde avec une grande attention le
mystère reste donc entier autour de ba2
le ministre de la santé a lui indiqué
que des personnes infectées par omicron
pourrait potentiellement être contaminé
par ce souriant au cours de la semaine
dernière sur 6000 séquençage ray 10 et
60 cas ont été détectés en france et en
israël un laboratoire pour ainsi dire de
la planète le comité consultatif
recommande une quatrième dose de vaccin
à tous les adultes simplement après un
rétablissement de la maladie où
l'administration du rappel ces
recommandations seront toutefois soumise
à l'approbation du directeur général du
ministère de la santé litterna santé
israélien qui affirme dimanche que la
quatrième dose de vaccin pour les
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus au
frais une protection triple contre les
maladies graves et de protection double
contre les infections se booster serait
toutefois moins efficace pour lutter
contre le variant omicron
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis tel aviv en israël avec un pool
as d'ailleurs journaliste d'arte et
internationale bonsoir paula le comité
consultatif on vient de le dire qu'il
recommande une quatrième dose de vaccin
à tous les adultes quelles sont les
réactions sur place a en france on le
sait il ya quelques récalcitrants qui
n'apprécierait pas effectivement eu une
quatrième dose comment on réagit dans
l'état hébreu
plus d'un demi million de personnes sont
contaminées par l'aco vide non plus
exactement à 590 personnes
hyères 83 mille nouveaux cas ont été
enregistrés
c'est la deuxième journée consécutive où
ont été enregistrés plus de 80 mille
nouveaux cas
les ministres de la santé a déclaré
qu'une wii 80 doses
pourraient être considérés pour les
personnes âgées et avait été décidée
pour les personnes âgées et les
personnes vulnérables
il ne s'agissait pas à l'époque d'une
décision facile et il n'envisage pas de
l'étendre à toute la population
pour le moment il s'agit simplement des
personnes de plus de 60 ans et des
personnes vulnérables originaux comprimé
consultatif est composée de 50 membres
une majorité de ses membres a voté en
faveur d'un quatrième dose d'entre eux
ont dit que cette quatrième doses
devraient être destinés aux personnes de
plus de 40 ans et huit personnes on dit
et que cela devait être uniquement
destiné aux personnes à risque alors au
4ème d'auzat de father of modern art
augmente le niveau d'anticorps chez les
personnes vaccinées mais le sérum et est
moins efficace un contre mikron selon un
communiqué de presse publié hier par un
hôpital près de tel aviv ce n'est pas un
pain contresens
même si vous l'avez préciser ces
réserves est une catégorie de personnes
enfin si c'est pas efficaces contre le
varié en dominant
d'après le professeur qui a mené l'étude
sans doute pas une bonne idée d'injecter
une autre quatrième dose à la population
générale ce qui correspond à sec a
déclaré le ministre de la santé mais
pour les personnes qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables
alors cette quatrième dose est une bonne
idée dans le même temps elle a expliqué
que la campagne actuelle
qui vise les personnes de plus de 60 ans
et les personnes vulnérables devraient
être amendé afin d'ouvrir cette
vaccination aux personnes
âgées en général
elle a également déclaré que les jeunes
ne sont pas les plus explosées ne sont
pas les plus malades de la coved elle ne
pensons pas qu'une quatrième dose est
nécessaire ou devrait être ouverte à la
jeunesse elle a déclaré que je serai
alors oui le comité consultatif
cependant a décidé d'encourager cette
quatrième dose tapez 1 et chiffre qui
montre que ceux qui ont reçu une
quatrième dose et qui ont plus de 60 ans
elles sont trois fois plus protégés face
à des formes graves de la maladie que
des personnes qui hélas ne neige reçue
ce que trois
il ya un clip en israël les jeunes
reçoivent trois doses et d'après les
experts cela devrait suffire mais que si
une personne de moins de 60 ans décide
de prendre une troisième cause alors
cela ne leur nuira pas cela ne peut que
renforcer la protection merci beaucoup
pour lier journalistes rt internationale
nous avoir exposé la situation dont dans
l'état hébreu merci à vous restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la campagne présidentielle
avec des candidats déclarés ou non
emmanuel macron était en haute vienne
aujourd'hui la candidate des
républicains
à tour quant à yannick jadot il a
détaillé son projet pour la
présidentielle alors campagne
présidentielle départ imminent rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi il s'est tourné
vers le communisme il pensait que la
gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne donc il regardait
l'union soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
le résultat un peu réservé bien des
surprises pour mieux comprendre nous
vous aiderons à y voir clair
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et l'unité est essentielle
de l'aventuré c'est pas tellement
laventure scientifique mais c'est
d'abord une recherche de supériorité
stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
s'expose à séoul on ne peut échapper aux
publicités invitant à modifier son
apparence
beaucoup de coréens considère la
chirurgie esthétique comme un préalable
indispensable à une carrière réussie les
employeurs accordent une attention
particulière à l'apparence des candidats
les parents offrent souvent leur fille
une opération de chirurgie esthétique à
la fin de leurs études sur la double
paupières pour agrandir les yeux
presque tous les adolescents coréen rêve
de ressembler à leur idole du monde de
lacq et pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'est octroyé un pourboire de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'ai su tout et des
réponses mais émettra 20 si jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise sans que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu
hitler et ses potes à la radio puis
toutes les choses graves j'ai
l'impression qu'on les apprend par la
radio quand on écoute la radio on sait
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
le kremlin de toul a été érigée au 16e
siècle à l'époque des incursions des
tatars et des peuples de crime à une
époque de féroces batailles et de
campagne militaire
ici on défend des héroïquement les
abords de moscou dit encore cinq siècles
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas seulement une
attraction touristique
à présent le kremlin de toula est l'un
des musées les plus visités du pays et
conserve de nombreux secrets qui ont
survécu jusqu'à nos jours après 500 ans
de guerre et de paix c'est un endroit où
le passé rencontre le futur
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la campagne présidentielle avec
des candidats déclarés ou non à la
conquête des français aujourd'hui avant
de se rendre à berlin emmanuel macron et
et en haute-vienne pour évoquer les
problématiques de la ruralité la
candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse était quant à elle à tours pour
parler justice à gauche aussi on
sillonne la france malgré lé division
yannick jadot et détaillé son projet
pour la présidentielle alors en pagne
présidentielle départ imminent on attend
vos réactions télégramme sur le compte
d'air t france
à moins de 80 jours maintenant de
l'élection présidentielle la campagne
bat désormais son plein emmanuel macron
a poursuivi ce matin son immersion de
deux jours dans le limousin sur le thème
de la ruralité l'actuel locataire de
l'elysée a assuré qu'il ne qu'il se
prononcerait en temps voulu sur sa
candidature la candidate des
républicains elle a de son côté détaillé
ces mesures en matière de justice
valérie pécresse qui tiendra son premier
grand meeting le 13 février prochain au
zénith à paris quant à yannick jadot il
était cet après midi à la rochelle pour
le forum européen de l'eau ce matin chez
nos confrères de france info le candidat
écologiste a détaillé son projet pour la
présidentielle il n'a d'ailleurs pas
hésité à tacler manuel à cran sur le
bilan de son quinquennat nicolas petit
à moins de trois mois de la
présidentielle les choses s'accélèrent
discret jusqu'à présent yannick jadot a
décidé de lever le voile sur son
programme
la même semaine que la primaire de la
gauche il est notamment revenu sur la
suppression de l' isf par emmanuel
macron au début de son quinquennat
une faute politique selon le candidat
écologiste qui compte le rétablir et le
renforcer on remettra un isf qui sera
sur les 1% les plus riches donc à partir
d'un patrimoine de 2 millions d'euros et
cet isf sera progressif il aura un
rendement de 20 milliards d'euros c'est
extrêmement intéressant et au delà de la
nécessaire solidarité des plus riches il
y à l'idée d'un bonus malus sur le
caractère plus ou moins écolo des
personnes fait plutôt rare yannick jadot
est d'accord avec emmanuel macron sur un
point la nécessité d'une réforme des
retraites remisé au placard par le chef
de l'état en raison du contexte
sanitaire deux visions qui s'opposent
toutefois puisque le chef de file des
écologistes s'il est élu au mois d'avril
souhaite revenir sur certaines mesures
prises par emmanuel macron concernant le
comte pénibilité en 2017 quatre facteurs
de risques au travail avait été
supprimée réduisant les possibilités de
retraite anticipée nous ne toucherons
pas à la retraite mais nous toucherons à
la pénibilité c'est un enjeu majeur nous
ferons de cette injustice énorme
d'espérance de vie un point central de
notre projet et nous mettrons le comte
pénibilité au coeur d'une grande réforme
des retraites vous préférez signé d
armistice avec les lobbys plutôt que de
mener la guerre contre le dérèglement
climatique
mercredi dernier yannick jadot avait
pris tout le monde de court en
s'adressant directement au chef de
l'état dans l'hémicycle du parlement
européen
il avait alors qualifié de président de
l'inaction climatique
un coup d'éclat pour le candidat europe
ecologie les verts qui souhaitent
exister politiquement après un début de
campagne jugée trop prudent par son
entourage même autre point d'achoppement
le dossier ukrainien sur lequel yannick
jadot espère davantage de signaux forts
de la part du chef de l'état je regrette
que le président de la république pas
son temps à recevoir poutine à brégançon
où à versailles et qu'il ne soit pas
allé une fois à kiev je l'appelle à
organiser un sommet à kiev pour montrer
l'unité de l'europe si pour l'heure les
intentions de vote ne décolle pas avec
des sondages qui plafonne à 5 % au
premier tour yannick jadot semble bien
déterminé à inverser la tendance et à
déployer une stratégie offensive
alors une campagne qui a donc démarré
pour certains une campagne qui ne dit
pas son nom pour le maquereau qui a
défendu son bilan tout au long de cette
visite de deux jours dans limousin en
coulisses les états majors des candidats
s'organisent les grands meetings
repoussé à cause du coc vide également
d'une autre débat ce soir présidentielle
le débat est-il imminent elle des
candidats sont-ils dans les starting
blocks on attend vos réactions sur notre
compte télégramme et place à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
tommaso vos skis porte parole de ratte
de la france et soutien du parti la
reconquête d'eric zemmour bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous david xavier weiss
maire adjoint l est républicain de
levallois-perret soutien de valérie
pécresse bonsoir à vous aussi et par
liaison skype alexis poulain
éditorialistes arte france qui nous
accompagnent bonsoir alexis on commence
par vous d'ailleurs soixante quinze
jours maintenant du premier tour de
l'élection il ya comme une petite voilà
une petite frustration pour les
aficionados de la politique française où
sont les les grands débats les les
grands meetings et les déplacements de
terrain des candidats alexis alors il y
en a il y avait jean luc mélenchon à
bordeaux en début de semaine car en plus
une salle au delà même les gens étaient
dans la rue il ya anne hidalgo qui a
essayé elle de remplir une salle à
aubervilliers on voit que des meetings
vont arriver valérie pécresse qui va
faire un meeting à surveiller cette
armée a eu à le faire et puis eric
zemmour à cannes qui avait là encore
rempli une salle donc il y à des
meetings il ya une campagne qui a lieu
sur le terrain bien sûr tout une une
campagne qui prend du temps où les
candidats n'ont pas forcément tous deux
programmes et où il ya encore des
candidats qui ne sont pas tout à fait
déclaré christiane taubira attend le
résultat de la fameuse primaires
populaires 1 400 mille inscrits en ligne
est-ce qu'ils vont tous voter pour elle
le suspense reste entier pour les autres
c'est déjà commencé la course bien sûr a
commencé depuis longtemps et puis les un
candidat non déclaré qui n'arrête pas
d'être en campagne dans les campagnes
françaises c'est emmanuel macron qui va
faire le tour de france dès la semaine
prochaine donc sa candidature devrait
être imminente puisque tout est prêt au
siège de la république en marche et
ailleurs
on voit bien que la campagne a commencé
on attend plus finalement que ce go
demel macron qui va se présenter à sa
réélection pour que les choses
deviennent un peu plus
chaude un peu plus intéressante on va
dire ça serait bien effectivement on va
en parler de ce rôle un emmanuel macron
facettes place en tout cas d' emmanuel
macron proéminente alors qu'il n'est pas
encore déclaré candidat nous on va jeter
un petit oeil sur l'agenda parce que
vous l'avez dit ya quand même quelques
meetings il faut en parler yannick jadot
le 29 janvier qui avait représenté son
programme à lyon 5 février convention
présidentielle de marine le pen à reims
et une meeting d'eric zemmour à lille 1
6 février meeting de fabien roussel à
marseille et 13 février meeting de
valérie pécresse à paris voilà qui est
dit il va y avoir d'ailleurs du sport le
5 février affrontements à distance entre
marine le pen et eric zemmour tommaso
vos skis vous avez on l'a vu cette
semaine davantage de soutien vous devez
être heureux mais enfin est-ce qu'on
vous avez les parrainages pour y aller
avant d'entamer le débat sur campagne ou
pas parce que c'est vrai que c'est
important oui pardon oui donc vous
parler de campagne revient sur les
parrainages moi j'ai pas une information
interne de l'équipe d'eric zemmour
depuis l'arrivée de guillaume pelletier
d'une part vain de nous de sébastien
pilar de pas mal de monde des
républicains et de l'autre des anciens
d'ailleurs qui souvent étaient des
anciens des républicains comme monsieur
rivière qui a été un moment aux
républicains avant par ces aura sûrement
nationale et des anciens du rpr qui
était pas satisfait dlr il y a quand
même c'est arrivé de soutien à rassurer
un surnom de mr doc et des choses qui
arrivent mais enfin c'est quand même
très difficile vu le système et vu la
fin de l'anonymat qui a été décidé par
monsieur hollande qui rend les choses un
peu compliquées pour rien parce qu'on
voit bien que normalement des candidats
comme règle zemmour ou d'autres tous
ceux qui sont autour d'eux 10% 15% des
intentions de vote devraient pouvoir
avoir leur parrainage donc façon je
pense a pas empêché eric zemmour de
commencer à faire campagne même avant
d'être candidat on lui reprocher donc la
campagne continue et ça change pas grand
chose pour nous la question est
importante parce que peut-être que ça
motive quand on est sûr d'y aller
jusqu'au bout david xavier weiss à
valérie pécresse elle a été la dernière
ce matin officialisé son premier grand
meeting le 13 février on a dit c'est à
dire pas avant quinze jours vous la
trouvez assez visible votre candidate
sur la scène médiatique et et plus de
telles visées elle même il faut qu'elles
font de l'armure est ce que on en fait
assez pour qu'elle soit connue justement
c'est bon je pense que valérie pécresse
est assez connu que ce soit en région
ile de france bien sûr sa terre
d'élection mais aussi sur le réseau la
france le vrai problème il n'est pas là
il est sur le fait qu'on a un président
de la république qui saturent les médias
et qui sature tous les plateaux télé et
un et de président de la république qui
est candidat sans le dire donc il ya une
forme de mensonge de travestissement de
la réalité et finalement ils abusent
aussi les français aussi bien les
français que le csa puisque normalement
le csa devrait au moins impliqué les
mêmes contraintes en matière de temps
quand vous êtes devant votre poste de
télé vous avez effectivement un emmanuel
macron a agi quasiment h 24 avec les
retransmissions et vous avez très peu de
place pour les autres candidats encore
l'élection de son bilan il est supposé
être décomptés comme les autres mais
c'est vrai que la frontière est toujours
un aimant il ya le yagha celui à son
bilan et à se le fait qu'il est
président qu'il est président candidat
et puis elle fait qu'il est monsieur
chat qui fait des chèques alors voitures
voilà alors ce matin c'était le
gouvernement qui annonce est de 10 %
d'augmentation tant mieux c'est une
reprise d'une demande de valérie
pécresse preuve que finalement les idées
qui émergent au sein de l'équipe de
valérie pécresse sont reprises un peu un
peu un peu de façon éhontée par ce
gouvernement mais on a aussi le fameux
déplacement à nice où il a annoncé un
chèque de 15 milliards pour la police à
horizon 2050 avec un programme hôtel de
police à nice qui ne verra le jour qu'en
2025 26 et permis de confier n'étant pas
encore donné donc on a quand même un
président en campagne qui est un peu un
président bonimenteur un vrp de la
république en marche qui fait des
chèques qui fait des promesses et pour
le moment ils saturent l'écran à défaut
de laisser la place aux autres candidats
quel que soit d'ailleurs les autres
candidats de droite comme de gauche
serait que clairement comme un voleur de
base ball au ski pardon quand on est un
autre candidat ça doit être compliqué
d'exister dans le paysage médiatique
aujourd'hui on s'en plaint de votre côté
nous ne soutenons pas je pense qu'on
existe médiatiquement la campagne tourne
autour d'eric zemmour dont on ne voit
pas dire qu'on a du mal à exister le
tourne autour de nos propositions
c'est le président donc il inaugure les
chrysanthèmes
il parle il utilise la période des voeux
mois janvier c'est de bonne guerre moi
je pense qu'au contraire il ya un
problème il n'arrive pas à se déclarer
candidat qu'est ce que ça veut dire
politiquement il n'a rien à vendre son
bilan est calamiteux il n'a pas de
projet sirh qu'il a cherché pendant
quatre ans déjà un projet puisqu'en fait
il avait été élu sur une forme d'
esbroufe un projet complètement vide
badou l'égide et jaunes font des choses
un peu un peu catastrophique
soi-disant une opposition au fascisme
marine le pen quand on voit ce qui fait
que pas sanitaires et la privation de
liberté qu'on a aujourd'hui on sait pas
vraiment où ils fascistes dans ce pays
moi j'ai quand même des gros problèmes
de liberté sur ce qu'on nous impose
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui eric zemmour
est le seul à s'imposer clairement face
à ça dans les grands candidats donc
aujourd'hui en fait office de besoin
nous avons passé les nerfs au moins est
en tout cas en tout cas il n'a pas de
projet il ne sait pas où il va et son
seul projet c'est moi président c'est ce
qu'il a repris de françois hollande et y
compris toute sa politique socialiste
donc il essaie narcisse emmanuel macron
il admire dans le poste de télévision il
est ivre de lui-même de se montrer et
effectivement comme vous l'avez souligné
juste raison il renie le début de son
candidat quelques mois avant l'élection
sur le nucléaire c'est encore pire il à
fermer fessenheim il a dit qu'on allait
arriver à 50% nucléaire et depuis
quelques mois alors isolé j'ai bien
écouté attentivement même avant de
rejoindre eric zemmour les propositions
d'eric zemmour sur le nucléaire de
nouveau de nouveau
deux nouveaux réacteurs une vraie
politique nucléaire maintenant il fait
tout l'un vers de ce qu'il a fait depuis
le début du quinquennat donc
effectivement il est mal à l'aise parce
que je ne sais pas ce qu'il va faire
comme campagne et s'il a beau être très
fort en termes de communication le
problème ça va être l'action et ils
retardent le moment on va pouvoir juger
son bilan catastrophique et son absence
totale de projet justement premier
message télégramme 1 à la question de
savoir le départ est imminent les
candidats sont-ils dans les starting
blocks 1 marion 92 nous dit celui qui
est dans les starting blocks sans le
dire c'était manuel macron il veut nous
refaire le coup du hold up alexis
poulain ces sept c'est la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron justement de se déclarer
le plus tard possible ou dans le fond ça
change pas grand chose
non c'est évidemment sa stratégie de se
déclarer le plus tard possible de le
faire de manière la moins ostentatoire
possible également pour assurer une
continuité c'est moi le président c'est
à dire que c'est un défilement devant
son bilan il ne peux pas le défendre
c'est un bilan catastrophique il n'a pas
pu faire les réformes qu'il avait
proposé la crise du gilet jaune n'a pas
été géré correctement parlons pas de la
crise sanitaire 500 mille cas que vides
alors que le pass vaccinale entre en
vigueur bon bref c'est n'importe quoi
donc ils évitent de gérer son bilan donc
il veut se déclarer le plus tard
possible et puis il ya autre chose on
voit qu'il commence à dévisser dans les
sondages avec edouard philippe loin
devant lui et d'autres candidats qui
vont commencer à également lui passer
devant même si les sondages ont toujours
été plutôt favorable à emmanuel macron
donc à partir du moment où il perd sa
stature présidentielle il perd tout son
intérêt finement il devient un candidat
avec un bilan difficile à gérer a pas
défendre et avec un projet qu'il n'a pas
encore c'est à dire c'est donnez moi
cinq ans de plus pour continuer à faire
ce que je n'ai pas fait c'est in
entendable françois hollande à sa place
avait finalement choisi de ne pas se
représenter parce qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas faire face à aux français et
demande oui bien sûr by ap peut-être en
corrèze mais apparemment nous mais
toujours dans le débat mais pourrait
voler le macron sa stratégie est simple
je fais des propositions jeu sort le
chéquier des français c'est notre argent
qu'il met sur la table et j'évite de
parler de mon bilan je ne laisse même
pas ça mais ministre personne ne doit
parler et j'attire les caméras puisque
je suis un phénomène de foire mcfly et
carlito d'un côté les youtuber d'un côté
et puis sur le terrain de manière
organisée avec les caméras pour me
montrer sous mon meilleur jour mais
c'est de la coop c'est de l'esbrouffe ça
a été ça a marché en 2010 est je crois
que ça va être très difficile en 2022 de
continuer sur cette lancée qui n'en est
pas une puisque il n'y a pas de
dynamique et le danger c'est qu'une fois
déclarer candidat emmanuel macron davis
rapidement dans les sondages en tout cas
lui il fait comprendre qu'il est bien le
maître des horloges écoutez le
aujourd'hui lors de son déplacement dans
les mauges à
[Musique]
tout avait été réglé et pas le cas
j'annoncerai ma décision
clairement qu'est ce qu'on se dit du
côté des soutiens de valérie pécresse
qu'il est temps enfin qu'il se déclare
une question d'honnêteté de de noyauter
question d'honnêteté vis-à-vis des
français effectivement on sait très bien
qui m'allume à quick candidat à sa
réélection ça ne fait aucun doute il l'a
dit à demi-mot d'ailleurs pendant ses
voeux il a dit il avait même dit au
moins de fin décembre quand il avait
fait son mea culpa en dix ans là j'ai
découvert les franges et eurent
découvert la fin que les français
avaient des fins de mois difficiles
qu'ils étaient parfois 10 euros c'est
triste de découvrir que la france et les
français après cinq ans d'exercice du
mandat mais ça voulait bien dire qu'il
était candidat à sa réélection or
aujourd'hui il abuse d'un système pour
justement profiter médiatiquement de
cette ambiguïté de candidat président il
est candidat à sa réélection ça ne fait
aucun doute d'ailleurs il ya qu'à voir
devant rue du rocher devant le qg de
campagne et enfin devant le siège de
deux de la république en marche on voit
bien que ça s'active pour cette campagne
présidentielle donc qu'il ne qu'il
arrête de mentir au moins pour ça au
moins pour ça ça sa déclaration de
candidature
il faut arrêter de mentir aux français
ou arrêter de les prendre pour des pour
des idiots en tout cas marine le pen
elle elle demande clairement au
président qu'il sorte de l'ambiguïté
côté
emmanuel macron ne peut pas être
candidat à sa réélection et continuer à
se comporter comme le président de la
république avec tous les avantages que
cela comporte pour le débat démocratique
il doit être à la portée des arguments
de ses adversaires
vous demander la même chose à la
reconquête au président de la république
clairement tout se déclare moi moi je
trouve que c'est j'ai pas forcément
envie de rentrer dans ce débat là parce
que ça donne un peu côté
qu'on doit de donner l'impression de se
plaindre génère on a des arguments alors
vous savez on a 80 mille adhérents la
reconquête qui doit être constatée par
huissier enfin ou qu'ils devaient pour
ceux traités par l'uci parce qu'on nous
faisait un procès donc on a autant que
les républicains avant avant le congrès
où ça devient une question de cartes
mois était fait pour le congrès des
cartes valables mais qui seront pas
forcément des grands des grands
militants mais enfin je veux dire tout
cas c'est des vrais militants qui sont
sur le terrain pardon je ressens dit
qu'ils soient qui sont sur le terrain
des traces paris mais au nom aussi
on a quelques mois d'existence donc
c'est autre chose on va aller sur le
terrain on va déjà sur le terrain
rencontrer les français avec des
arguments avec des propositions pour
revenir sur la mine elle macro mais je
trouve que le problème c'est que sur ce
sur quoi ils devraient être président
est un président mal je prends deux
exemples la rentrée scolaire a été
catastrophique avec des protocoles
complètement ubuesque que soit ibiza ou
pas ibiza c'est complètement délirant ce
qui se passe dans les écoles les quarts
en assemblée j'ai gardé les enfants chez
eux on dépense alors pour le coup un
pognon dingue comme d'idées comme dit
notre président pour faire des tests qui
ne servent à rien chez les enfants donc
cet argent aurait dû être quand même
plutôt à l'hôpital chez les soignants ou
pour soigner les gens qui peuvent
peut-être arrivé en urgence donc ça
c'est qu'il ne sait pas travailler donc
il est en train de préparer sa campagne
il délaisse la gestion du pays en
faisant n'importe quoi
la crise ukrainienne la limite il faut
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient présents il
ne l'est pas il laisse faire n'importe
quoi
on voit qu'il n'est pas vraiment à la
manoeuvre en tant que président
donc qui se déclarent ou plus et
déclarent pas de toute façon on va tout
faire pour qu'il ne soit pas réélu et ça
nous empêche pas de parler en français
ce qu'on va continuer à faire sur le
terrain et on n'a pas besoin je pense
que les français ont besoin de proximité
on a réussi on fait de beau meeting
depuis longtemps avec eric zemmour on va
continuer à en faire y compris en
province pas seulement dans les grandes
villes pour aller au contact des
français et nous la campagne plus que
jamais lancés depuis des mois et comme
disait nicolas sarkozy on commence à
fond et on accélère donc la campagne en
tout cas cher reconquête est lancé et on
n'attend pas la déclaration des miels
macron plus elle tendra à mon avis moi
ce sera bon pour lui mais il déclarera
quand il voudra nous on est là pour qui
ce soit dans quelques mois la fin de son
premier unique et dernier mandat alors
il ya quand même les sondages qui le
donnent encore largement en tête même
s'il baisse en ce moment regardez ce
sondage ifop le dernier en date un 24 5%
pour le président de la république c'est
moins un point marine le pen 18% valérie
pécresse 16.5 eric zemmour art contest
12% et jean luc mélenchon 10 5% quand
est ce sont david xavier weiss vous
dites quoi parce que c'est vrai que le
nombre voilà de satisfaits du président
de la république est relativement élevé
pour l'instant votre candidate n'est pas
qualifié au second tour il ya de la
fébrilité de l'inquiétude tout de même
dû a pas d'inquiétude pas de fébrilité
on vous savez valérie pécresse elle
développe et le détail ces différentes
propositions on va aller à la rencontre
des français il reste 75 jours
effectivement utile pour pour cette
campagne elle dirige à elle y est déjà
elle est déjà en campagne elle a déjà
fait le tour de france du jet depuis
deux points depuis le mois de juillet
moi je ne suis pas du tout inquiet
d'autant que si eric zemmour se
maintient et à ses parrainages
effectivement on va avoir un équilibre
entre
l'électorat des guides d'eric zemmour et
marine le pen on vous sent bien que
marine le pen est en perte de vitesse et
que les électeurs vont plutôt vers vers
eric zemmour qui est notre dynamique qui
plaît cette frange de l'électorat et
avec cet effet ciseaux on aura une
valérie pécresse qui s'acquiert contrat
emmanuel mapon second tour moi j'en suis
persuadé les sarments et sincèrement vu
le rejet actuel du président la
république parce qu'effectivement elle a
un socle à 25% mais où le second tour
c'est plus difficile de rassembler les
français ce qui en revanche en capacité
de faire valérie pécresse rendez-vous au
second tour je pense que valérie
pécresse a une bonne candidate de second
tour emmanuel macron est un bon candidat
premier tour alexis poulain ce
raisonnement vous demande pas évidemment
de dettes madame irma ce soir m'enfin
c'est vrai que plus exhibe moore se
maintient plus il a des chances de faire
baisser marine le pen peut-être
mécaniquement et de faire accéder les
graisses au second tour c'est une
analyse qui est qui est réel aujourd'hui
et après un vrai danger pour emmanuel
macron avec valérie pécresse au second
tour oui c'est entendable valérie
pécresse elle n'était pas attendue
finalement de cette primaire ça a
compliqué les plantes des malades macron
qui attendait un xavier bertrand de
manière plus classique donc elle l
absolu mais le trouble pour la
république en marche clairement pour
emmanuel macron aussi qui doit revoir sa
stratégie d'une certaine façon et les
républicains savent très bien qu'en
appuyant les signatures les parrainages
pour eric zemmour ils vont faire baisser
mécaniquement marine le pen puisque on
voir que reconquête à une dynamique
comme assez forte il arrive à 7 ce
nouveau parti attirer des cadres du
rassemblement national jérôme rivière
mais d'autres qui ont rejoint dès ce
week end eric zemmour donc pour marine
le pen ça va être plus compliqué
d'accéder mécaniquement au second tour
puisque son assise va petit à petit
c'est rodez en fonction de la façon dont
eric zemmour va mener sa campagne pour
les républicains la difficulté c'est de
se différencier des manuels à croquer ce
que valérie pécresse va pouvoir apporter
pour montrer qu'elle est bien différente
des malades macron sur blain nombre de
sujets que ce soit la gestion sanitaire
mais aussi le pouvoir d'achat la crise
du coc vide je venais de le dire
l'europe également il ya beaucoup de
points communs quand même chez les
républicains avec
une partie du programme d'e mails macro
qui va falloir éclaircir et aujourd'hui
si valérie pécresse à un effort à faire
c'est un effort de clarification pour
être sûr finalement de se différencier
radicalement du président de la
république
vous avez là le même diagnostic qu'ont
certains français 1 de cette lisibilité
de différence entre valérie pécresse et
emmanuel macron elle n'a toujours pas
tirer les choses au clair
absolument je je je fais juste une qui
rebond tout à l'heure moi cette campagne
me fait penser à celle de 95 ans on
disait que edouard balladur était chance
d'arriver au second tour de badges à ce
point que c'est chirac y arriver alors
qu'il était pendant très longtemps très
bas dans les sondages donc pour moi
jacques chirac de cette élection serrée
xoom ou d'autres ont d'autres analyses
en tout cas disons que les jeux ne sont
pas faits ce que j'ai quand même
toujours j'ai toujours remarqué il ya
une ferveur sur le terrain qui rappelle
chirac 94 95 et sarkozy 2007 c'est un
président garant l'élection a lieu un
mois plus tôt et avec un contexte
sanitaire qui gèle quant à elle en
partie des grands meetings ces grandes
manifestations populaires y avait du
monde à cairns mais il parle de nous et
démonstrations de morphée personne n'y
allait pas autant de 20 du personnel on
ne fait pas autant de meetings avant et
c'est pas une question de derry zemmour
de valérie pécresse s'il ya un constat
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile
d'organiser ses meetings avec les
contraintes sanitaires qui sont
actuellement posées partout et c'est
vrai que ça gèle aussi le débat un peu
le débat démocratique et ça ça avantage
pour le moment ça avantage emmanuel
macron jusqu'au jour où effectivement
les français vont encore mais ça veut
dire y'en a marre de se faire confisquer
cette élection c'est un petit peu un
hold-up démocratique encore une fois
différent de 2017 mais cette fois ci
c'est 1,2 démocratique qui joue pas
devant la devant la cour de justice
devant le pnf mais qui se joue sur un
contexte sanitaire mal gérée mais
savamment entretenue aussi longtemps
répondre à votre question sur le contact
sanitaire effectivement je pense qu'un
point de clarification je pense que tous
sont valérie pécresse elle va tout cette
campagne confrontés à une grande
question elle a quitté l'est républicain
est-ce que c'était trop à droite et
maintenant elle nous fait le karcher le
kouchner
les charters
les gens ne sont pas dupes les gens de
son art du la palladienne
la
ligne droite avait une ligne droitière
et surtout le problème la gestion de
laurent wauquiez qu'une gestion à
l'époque très clanique et qui est car
c'est parce qu'elle a dit les partis
réunis pas retirer trop adroits
lentilles et voilà quand les pas de
place pour une diversité un pluralisme
scality ce qu'a été le cas de l'ump dès
le début de sa construction le mps et l
union de la droite et du centre si à la
fin on ne se retrouve qu'avec une frange
très droitière on est en train de perdre
une forme de l'électorat centriste qui
doit se retrouver dans dans l'avenir
analyse la paire grise pour après des
centristes mais élaboré avec monsieur la
garde bien qu'il ait fait une phrase
absolument indigne de la vie politique
française certes dans une situation en
direct mais qui voulait dire que eric
zemmour mérité une balle dans la tête on
ne peut pas prendre le pas on peut faire
un dix d'actu délit mais pas avec
monsieur la guerre dont moi je pense
comme un décret déjà une faute politique
là dessus en acceptant le soutien de
l'udes et y est de conserver sur la
garde à la tête de l'ue dit et on sait
ce que c'est cette partie sans dieu lui
dit que non il ya eu dans les élus de
l'uni aux dernières municipales ont été
soutenus par la république en marche
c'est bien mais c'est pas vrai la liste
longue comme le bras non non non dans
les régions on a même bürkli qui
s'affiche à lier dwarf est libre on a
plein de centristes et de gens qui ont
une porosité avec en marche ça c'est la
première grosse blague de jean eric
zemmour qui a une pour résister avec
avec marine le pen et pour
qui ont rejoint zemmour et sur la crise
sanitaire je suis très frappé d'une
autre faute politique de valérie
pécresse qui s'affichent en permanence
avec un masque en extérieur dans ses
interventions qui prolonge de narrative
sanitaire des manuels macron madame
pécresse qui prend qui proposait de
repousser d'une semaine l'ouverture des
écoles elle enseigne les arts et nous
savons que la passion
à jean michel blanquer soleil vous
parler de la crise sanitaire on a en
tout cas pour faire simple pour moi elle
reste dans la surenchère pour faire peur
aux français sur la crise à l'inter elle
ne remet pas en cause les privations de
liberté et le narratif d'emanuel macron
sur le co vide qui est sa principale
force de campagne donc il faut pour se
démarquer de déminer le maquereau il
faut qu'elle clarifie cette ligne
d'ailleurs la commune et insulter les
gens si les gens n'ont pas respecté
la campana a débuté ce soir sur ce
bateau c'est bien merci
oui on va continuer évidemment merci
alexis poulain d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous deux ans david xavier weiss
et tommaso vos skis et c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouve à demain dès
20 heures pour un nouveau numéro et
l'actualité continue tout l'espace
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
il ya 30 ans l'union soviétique s'est
effondré comment avez vous perçu ces
événements à l'époque j'étais parmi les
partisans de la démocratie la rédaction
du journal russia se trouvait à la
maison blanche nous avons passé deux
nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à la
maison blanche on était au centre de
presse du ministère des affaires
étrangères lors de la célèbre conférence
de presse du comité d'état pour l'état
d'urgence j'ai bien sûr changé plusieurs
fois d'opinion sur ces événements comme
tout le monde s'en doute mais à ce
moment là il y avait bien sûr une sorte
d'euphorie démocratique ils
s'enthousiasment
et probablement si seulement j'avais pu
imaginer à l'époque en août 91 à quoi
aboutir et ces événements
ce nom se terminerait cet enthousiasme
joyeux dans la lutte contre le monopole
du parti communiste et la censure en
apprenait coppens mais personne ne
pensait que cela aboutirait à
l'effondrement d'un grand pays
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté vous remercie d'avoir
amitié
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'angoissé que le secret
purement russe n'existe pas j'dois pas à
l'oscar mais si une création russe t'as
qu'a eus atteint les sommets de l'art
mon analyse
très peu de gens dans le monde peuvent
rivaliser
on s'approche la culture russe c'est la
culture de la liberté c'est une culture
de grand sens et de grandes idées c'est
une culture sauvage c'est une culture
qui explosent
[Musique]
et 3
2 quoi
[Musique]
bienvenue dans afrique connect l'afrique
la nouvelle crypte hollande les chiffres
sont dithyrambiques le continent a reçu
plus de sens 1 1 milliard de dollars de
crypto monnaies entre juillet 2020 et
juin 2021 il se hisse au troisième rang
des progressions les plus rapides du
secteur des devises virtuelles selon le
cabinet américain d'analysé qui relève
une augmentation de 1200 % de ce marché
africain à l'heure où le bitcoin
traverse une zone de turbulences il est
passé sous la barre des quarante mille
dollars en septembre 2021 une première
et bien cet engouement sur le continent
contraste avec l'inquiétude des
investisseurs ailleurs ils sont nombreux
à se lancer dans l'aventuré comme l'ex
footballeur international togolais
donald sunoco moussac est président
directeur général et fondateur de
timeless capital technologies une
société ad crypto il est notre invité et
on se connecte avec lui bonjour à vous
donaldson nous que nous sec et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
fri connect ou non nous sommes un bon
jour samantha d'abord cette question je
les dis le beacon qui traverse une zone
de turbulences est ce que vous êtes
inquiet
non je ne suis pas inquiet parce que si
vous regardez en arrière en 2020 le prix
du bitcoin était compris entre 40 et 50
mille dollars aujourd'hui il est à 44
mille dollars donc
la plupart des grandes entreprises ont
investi dans le bitcoin les banques
commencent à accepter cette devise sur
le long terme il est certain que la
valeur du bouquin